hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be an explanation for x-23 the way
they're using are in the movie the
future of the Wolverine character so
let's break it down the real point of
the latest trailer is just to give you a
better idea for the story and confirm
the fact that it is the Laura Kinney
x-23 character so if you have no idea
who that is she is the 23rd attempt to
replicate the Weapon X program because
the sample they had was damaged she
wound up becoming a female clone instead
of a male clone like they had originally
intended but the person in charge of the
program Xander Rice is actually the son
of someone's that Wolverine himself
killed in the original Weapon X program
so he has a beef against Wolverine but
this clone is created from his genetic
material and she has adamantium claws
but her skeleton is regular so one of
the biggest questions I had in my
trailer video yesterday was how does she
grow if she has adamantium bones and I
almost forgot there actually is a new
round of the Deadpool giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video if the $20
comixology gift card but in the same way
that Wolverine revolted just completely
went berserk after he came out of the
tank in the Weapon X program so does
Laura Kinney in the reason she's named
Laura Kinney is because one of the other
people in that program was named dr.
Kinney she was tasked with raising her
so the movie does a good job of
explaining that we're like the little
girl has a mother but technically
because she's a clone she has no mother
she's just a piece of Wolverine so she's
the closest thing that he has to a
daughter and I know a lot of you are
asking about Daken Wolverine son from
the comics I'll do a separate video
about that because it's a completely
separate thing but they're trying to
keep the movie as simple as possible
so in this universe there is only X 23
there's no Daken so X 23 is raised in
captivity of sorts for about 7 years
training with the doctor that was
responsible for creating her but the
person in charge van der rice isn't
happy with the progress she's making
they're trying to train a killer here
it's the Weapon X Pro
but she just this normal little girl so
he creates something called the trigger
scent and uses it on dr. Kinney causing
Laura
x-23 to Hulk out on her and kill her
best friend so make all the trigger
jokes you want but that's basically
what's happening in these trailers here
where she goes into berserker rage to
try and save Logan from these people in
the context of the movie in these scenes
is just a little bit different because
you have a really old Logan it's like
2029 that's the year so it said way
after that Days of Future past
post-apocalyptic timeline you remember
at the end of that movie they fix things
so imagine this taking place
well after that the director said he
wanted to be far enough away from those
events that there wasn't any mixing or
matching with plot lines like this
wasn't just the next episode this was
like way further in the future so most
of Logan's regeneration powers have
waned he doesn't heal as fast and it
hurts him to fight so he doesn't want to
fight but the x-23 character is fresh
off the genetic printing press she has
all of his ferocity so she's like this
exacto blade of rage whereas Wolverine
is kind of like the dulled instrument so
he can still totally Hulk out when he
needs to when he's pushed over the line
but for the most part you have to
imagine that he is a lot like the older
Professor X here he just doesn't look it
so he's very tired in Professor X is
another matter - that's like a whole
other video the death of Professor X
there's been about 10 times in the
comics that Wolverine his diet they've
also been a couple big story arcs where
they've killed off Professor X but the
adamantium so like I said she has a
regular skeleton but just adamantium
claws that's how she grows normally so
what happened is is they bombarded her
with radiation to force the activation
of her X gene just in the same way the
Deadpool movie bombarded him with all
kinds of tests to try and activate his X
gene once she does they bond her claws
with adamantium and then she makes her
escape Wolverine style it's it's in the
same way he hooks out and just kills
everybody and runs off but because she's
so mad at Wolverine for May
her creation possible she killed her
best friend she thinks of herself as a
monster so she goes after the only
person she knows is ultimately
responsible so she blames Wolverine and
tries to track him down a bunch of
people close to her died but then once
she finally tracks Wolverine down they
come to terms he explains that he knows
what's going on and she gets arrested by
Captain America so the Avengers the
heroes the x-men they feel like she's
not responsible for all the deaths that
are on her head as she tried to escape
she goes on to start leading a normal
life trying to be a superhero in the
Marvel Universe but you still have
Vander rice in the Weapon X people in
the Reavers of this movie trying to
track her down so in the comics she was
already fully grown when she tracked
Wolverine down she's still just a little
girl in this movie but what does that
say about the future of the character so
we understand her past now we know what
she does in the movie she's basically
like a Wolverine that's fresh off the
printing press totally badass
totally ferocious but what are they
going to do if this movie is so far in
the future are they going to use the
character so the director said but he
didn't intend for her to take Wolverines
place or his mantle but he hopes the
fans embrace her like they really enjoy
the character so we make this sound like
the end of this movie doesn't suddenly
time travel into the past like there's
no crazy twist it's just a bookend for
the character where she just goes on and
tries to lead a normal life whatever
ends up happening to the Wolverine
character so with that in mind that just
leaves the other x-men films to reboot
the character with another actor if they
want if they're not going to do a
Deadpool Wolverine crossover which I do
think it's still very possible but the
real opportunity here for x-23 her
future in the x-men universe I think is
with the x-force movie so Wolverine has
a long history with x-force it's like a
more hardcore version of x-men I've
already done a couple x-force videos so
I'll add links at the end of this but
during volume 3 x-23 joined the team so
you could just do a version of that so
you get your Wolverine character even
though it's not Wolverine they don't
have to completely reboot the character
ahead of schedule they can still leave
room for Hugh Jackman to come back and
do a Deadpool crossover if he
want I think it's going to be a couple
years before they even talk about what's
going to happen with Wolverine going
forward but x-23 still wide open so let
me know they do x-force which they are
doing that movies in development do you
want them to include the x-23 character
but because of all the timeline problems
there's a couple hoops that you have to
jump through so I'd be cool with
whatever version they want to go with if
they want to go with the young version
just like in this movie or if they want
to go with a fully grown clone that'd be
great too let me know how do you want
Laura Kinney to appear in the other
x-men movies the beauty of all this is
that it sounds like there's going to be
a soft reboot for the main x-men films
anyway so I feel like whatever they
decide to do it'll totally be cool as
long as it's a good movie that's all
people care about but just remember the
Deadpool movie is actually going to give
birth to x-force because Cable has to
come first so this is all a couple years
down the road so there's plenty of time
to figure it out but let me know in the
comments what kind of x-men universe
videos do you guys want me to do going
forward I know you guys are big fans of
Deadpool big fans of Wolverine but is
there any x-men related videos you guys
want me to do or explainers just let me
know in the comments speaking of reboots
they just started announcing the actors
that are on the shortlist for the Green
Lantern movie it will probably change
but it's actually a pretty interesting
list and it involves Bradley Cooper
there's a hilarious story about his
audition for the original Green Lantern
movie that he lost out to Ryan Reynolds
on so I'll probably do a video for that
on Saturday there's also some new Star
Wars Episode 8 that I'm going to post so
it's going to be great where you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to learn all about the rock joining the
DC EU as Black Adam he is going to wreck
everything it's going to be awesome and
you can click here to learn all about
what's going on with this cool - thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight